that's the big news you're taking a
sculpture class at the Community College
it's not art its sons and as such it is
the thing that is gonna help us defeat
de veau we call if you will the one
thing that we've seen nay heard that can
actually harm to beau is he blowing
sound wave powers Louise he was killed
by Davos or whatever power she had is in
his hands now and now Joe
they're in ours watch this so I should
maybe should they come steps back if you
value your internal organs
[Music]
laughs Hills one-strike incapacitates to
think of two strikes
no more thinker I call it a sonic
scepter okay points for alliteration
basically just a big tuning fork my
goodness
well if I mean it's not just any tuning
fork this might be the most powerful
tuning fork in the multiverse you must
have laser shaved this thing down to the
name you write down the last angstrom as
a matter of fact child's play for me and
my thinking cap the sonic scepter mimics
is ebon sonic frequency so we can
penetrate a heretofore impenetrable
force field of DeVoe and here's the best
part because there's no tech involved
its cohort proof yes nice so now we just
need to figure out where to vote was
gonna appear next as a matter of fact
before you got here I scripted a
subroutine on the pocket dimension
predictor I'm gonna give us a massive
head start DeVoe is next location thank
you yesterday I thought you said that
wasn't possible
that's right snow I did say that
yesterday but today is a new day I've
got a million new ideas the cap and I
wrote firing on all cylinders give us in
your mind do a high enough plane you can
go anywhere I'm 9 mag that's really high
episode 418 lose yourself Barry and team
are trying to track down the last
remaining bus Mehta around here we call
him the folded man folded man follow the
man is the sort of off-the-grid hippie
I'm actually glad I stayed for that that
was trippy really being in the
meditation and he has the ability to go
into pocket dimensions to create his own
Ralph you think we're gonna kill DeVoe
the way that you're saying that makes me
think I'm supposed to say no
Ralph is sort of struggling with what to
do if they're confronted with the ball
ultimately if they can't defeat him you
know they've been 0 for 11 right now
well I am Not Afraid of the vote and
what he might do with me
I am afraid of what he might do to you
and iris and Caitlin and Cisco Joe Harry
Cecile if they can't stop him then
ultimately are they gonna have to kill
him it's sort of the last last a lesson
that Barry can teach Ralph is you don't
kill especially when you have powers
there's always another way
Devo has taken out everyone who's gotten
in his way and team flash they will
always be in his way
hey everybody we got brand new flash to
break down and we got confirmation on
the Harley Quinn movie it's actually
gonna be full blown birds of prey from
Chuck Dixon era so I'll try to explain
what's going on with everything flashed
up first then I'll talk about Harley
Quinn and there's a new round of that
flash ring giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video you can kind of see
as evidenced by the stab your version of
elongated man is sitting it closer to
the finale they're leaning away from
comedy and more intellectus the
straight-up drama that you saw during
the season 1 season 2 finale 'he's Edwin
Gauss is supposed to be the last bus
meta but they still have two others
including Ralph's Dib knee so elongated
man still a bus meta it's just sometimes
they don't call him out as that like oh
yeah eventually he's gonna need your
powers too because you actually see them
walking to the thinker's den so I am
wondering what the elongated man thinks
he can do to kill the thinker because if
Barry has trouble doing it that what
does the elongated man gonna do about it
because it sounds like that might not
work like usually you find in situations
like that where the hero makes the bad
call in the context of the flash where
the thinker is just jumping into
different people's bodies horror movies
style
you killed the villain but don't realize
that he's like slowly piping his
consciousness towards your brain before
it's too late
so that it winds up being this
self-fulfilling prophecy like usually
that's the price that people like that
pay like elongated man is kind of on the
fence right now like Barry's trying to
teach him to be a hero it sounds like
that's what the rest of the season is
gonna be about like how we don't kill
people even the ones that seem really
really terrible so we think largely it's
gonna be us watching them in execution
with some of these characters because I
think we have a pretty good idea of
where the season is going to land it is
a matter of how they pan out all these
twists including coffee shop girl
we're all expecting her to be related to
Barry at this point in it to have
something to do with though we are the
flash twist like there's always a set up
a payoff in a reversal like an oh [ __ ]
moment that you never saw coming at
least that they try to give you a moment
like that so I think that's when the
folded man and this trailer is talking
about expanding your mind into a
different region it's a little like the
comic book thinker run where Barry ends
up fighting the thinker in sort of a
mine space matrix type area where their
physical bodies don't matter so he could
just manifest anything that he wants the
thing about that story though like I
think I've said this in the past but it
was actually more of a straight-up riff
on the actual Matrix movies because the
thinker was more of a tech based villain
in the comic book run was released right
after the Matrix movies came out so it
was like oh very clearly they're trying
to do the Flash's version of a matrix
story the flash TV show has been taking
a different spin on that but they might
wind up with the same conclusion so I
would still recommend you reading that
comic book run if you want to find out
what's going on but depending on what
they teased in this episode I'll
reference moments from the comic book
but the Harley Quinn movie you may have
seen this morning look right as I was
getting ready to make my flash video
they announced that they had hired a
director they don't have a release date
for the movie yet but it's basically
Chuck Dixon era og birds-of-prey which
is original Black Canary in Barbara
Gordon as the Oracle character Gail
Simone is the one that added the
Huntress and turned it into more of a
trio and they just stuck from then on
for the most part they've been a Gotham
based team there was like a brief period
right before they canceled the title in
the late 2000s where they took them to
the west coast so just imagine Harlequin
big Batman characters this is gonna be
set in Gotham no idea of is just gonna
be those three characters and who the
main villain is going to be in whether
or not those three characters will team
up against that person like the Joker
could be the villain of the Harlequin
movie and that would totally work
because they have that weird
relationship still kind of waiting to
hear a little bit more about the movie
even though they said that the roster is
gonna be original Chuck Dixon they
didn't actually say that Barbara Gordon
will be Oracle they just said the Chuck
Dixon lineup in Oracle was a part of
that lineup not Batgirl Barbara Gordon
Batgirl didn't become a member of the
birds of prey team until the new 52 like
shirogane
the ability to walk and then during the
rebirth era she's still a younger
version of the character but if you guys
didn't know there's also a Batgirl movie
that they were developing with Joss
Whedon he left the project the same
person that wrote this Harlequin
birds-of-prey movie is gonna be writing
the Batgirl movie but no idea when that
would come out and if it would be the
same person portraying Barbara Gordon in
both movies Wonder Woman and spider-man
are really good examples of characters
that debuted as supporting cast in
somebody else's movie then went off to
their own spin-off movies so they could
be doing something like that in the back
girl movie will definitely be her as
Batgirl I mean it's literally in the
title so it does seem like this is gonna
be Chuck Dixon
Batgirl Barbara Gordon birds of prey
with Harley Quinn in that you know
they'll probably come together at some
point in the film after heard like a lot
of fighting I am kind of hoping that
they work in a little bit of Nightwing
I'll be fine if they don't put Batman in
the movie like you don't have to put
Batman in every single movie but what'll
happen is is new flash episode posting
later tonight I'll announce the flash
ring giveaway winner when I post that
probably got some time to post a little
bit of infinity war before that - just
because Avengers is literally dropping
in theaters next week so get hype it's
gonna be awesome click here for more new
flash and click here for more new
infinity war thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight